greetings from podcast village Monday
April first the church is brought to you
by one of my all-time favorites
manscaped listen don't cut your dick off
[ __ ] oh the suffering ends today with
manscape you get it done without the
pain they got precision tools for the
family jewels
okay manscaped has redesigned the
electric razor their invention is the
lawnmower a handheld razor with
skin-safe technology so it won't
Nick or snag your little [ __ ] ball
sack or your stomach is thick all right
do me a favor listeners from the church
can get 20% off your first order when
you use promo code church at manscape
calm manscape calm promo code Church and
if you order the perfect package to also
throw in a free travel bag when you use
the code Church that's manscape calm use
promo code church for 20% off your first
order and always keep your ballsack
clean the church is also brought to you
by audit listen right now it's flu
season heavy duty and I'm doing the best
I can to stay out of it you know why
shroom tech immune this is the time of
year flu when you're traveling planes my
brother ba shroom tech Emil will help
you get through all these colds and
[ __ ] flus I might get a little lung
congestion but it don't go the whole
[ __ ] way cuz I take the shroom tech
they also have shoot export don't assign
alpha brain so do me a favor go to on it
slash Church right now and get 10% off
your first order delivered to your house
the church is also brought to you by
something I'm very proud of I love all
my sponsors because I know that I could
use all the practicality on them but
this I'm very happy about and it's CBD
line cuz picking a reliable CBD company
is like [ __ ] pulling teeth but that
ends right now with your uncle Joey
I found the CBD whether it's gummies
whether it's the tinctures whether it's
smoking it with a vapor where I've been
listen they have vapors for everything
that you might need anything like
anxiety muscle soreness CBD Lyon is your
one-stop shop they got shatter they got
vapors they got everything so do me a
favor go to CBD line calm right now and
check out there
third party lab results yourself and
then get some [ __ ] CBDs and what you
do is press in church and check out and
the church family get 20% off who's
better than you take this [ __ ]
melee mikey rats talk to me
when I hear a beat like that I just wish
I had the the ability to just start
rhyming I know
[ __ ] tremendous do you know what I'm
saying like if you could just like I'm
up I can't do it nobody can like that
but I wish I could just start rhyming
and not even know how to write lyrics
like I'll even start right now I
wouldn't know where I've tried just to
[ __ ] around III can't even get out of
the [ __ ] like I'm not even the gate
doesn't open
there's not even a gate that opens that
son that's always add me and like I
watch the dirt yes when he was writing
songs yeah yeah six yeah you have to be
of a different type of brilliance yeah
that [ __ ] to hear the music in your head
yeah write the lyrics yeah it's just a
different [ __ ] game what you think of
that movie I enjoyed it
[ __ ] tremendously yeah music fans
right I'm cheering for these movies
because I know that you know that I know
that they're gonna greenlight the
wedding Skynyrd right there do it up
them down right now right I wanna show
the crazy gay [ __ ] I was trying to get
it out so that one's gonna be a little
touchy-feely but I know what the guy
wrote from let it Skynyrd Led Zeppelin
should be coming soon after that yeah I
want something very interesting last
night why I had insomnia I could not
sleep and I don't get pissed off having
to Simon my just right and I watch TV I
smoke dope but none that I fell asleep
at 3:00 i watch The Rolling Stones Olleh
Olleh oh okay they canceled their tour
they had a reschedule cuz Mick is
[ __ ] sick huh and some Mick Jagger
for anybody who knows anything about
Mick Jagger for them to reschedule he's
got to be saying yeah cuz that guy is a
[ __ ] true professional and he loves
money he's all about the [ __ ] paper
but I watched Olleh Olleh Olleh and it
was very interesting it was the South
American tour
leading up to Cuba oh how they had a
sneak into Cuba what year was this this
is two years ago
a year ago I didn't see this one the
stones did Cuba and my cousin's opened
up for them oh yeah Bandon cube opened
up for them so when I saw all they all a
South American tour go let me turn this
on and then go to Chile Brazil Boog why
they go to a bunch of countries but the
whole time they're trying to figure out
how they're gonna play in [ __ ] Cuba
ah so then Raul gives them the green
light and then Obama decides to go down
on the same day so they can't play on
the same day as Obama the Cuban
government says no it's too much [ __ ]
they'll go crazy right so they had to
move that date to the 25th then the week
of the concert the Pope raised his hand
and said how dare they play in a
Catholic country on Good Friday they got
to move it so they have to move it again
but Jagger's and I move it they got all
the equipment down there and they show
Mick coming on from the [ __ ] Cubans
hey we're nuts
they went [ __ ] nuts when he started
talking Spanish was he was he was
talking Spanish he spoke Spanish in all
the countries you know he this is you
have to watch the movie because I always
say arts all the same it's all the same
every yarn has you know the art of music
and the art of comedy most musicians are
were most comedians are musicians that
didn't have the balls to get a guitar ah
me ah I didn't have the balls to get the
guitar because I thought Tommy was easy
so if you notice a lot of comics the
fans of music yeah and it goes both ways
so at one time they shall make Jagger in
the film and he's got lines in his hands
he's got so he does research he has
somebody do research from where he's
going so when he goes up on stage you
know I'm saying you forgot you'll see
you guys will soon know one day you're
gonna be headliners and you're gonna go
into a town and you gonna be feeling
good about yourself and the feature act
is really a feature it's really a
headline it but he's featuring because
the club wants to be a stronger show
he's no threat to you but while he's up
there he's local
he's talking about a local references
he's talking about this restaurant when
you stand on line
and he's destroying them and you feel
like [ __ ] because you don't know
anything about the city and now you
gotta follow this nothing scares you
more than when somebody gets personal
with the town it's right in front in
front of you that's when you really
build the bond with a city when the sea
knows that you love that's why I love
every American city because I find
something to love and when they go on
the road you start talking about it
makes me he makes it easy for me to go
there when I go to Charlotte outside my
[ __ ] hotel there's a separate eye box
that with the onions I know exactly
which one you're talking about oh you
know what Charlie
yeah you know when you go to [ __ ] in
Houston you got to go to Papa does ah
Miami you got to go to this restaurant
and you start learning different things
about the city why you're a feature act
but you start but you but you feel like
when you go up in those cities to
ingratiate yourself to see to making it
so you're not just like popping in there
I you have to talk about something that
is popular in the city that you really
truly I got you when I go to Cleveland I
go to that restaurant every Friday to
get pastrami I got chill you know to get
the corned beef sandwich but I forget
the name of the place
Fryman you know different cities I'm
gonna Milwaukee there's a little Chinese
restaurant on the strip there by that by
the Italian well the old comedy Cafe was
tremendous you know you miss good
Chinese food in Milwaukee yeah that's
continued listen the block what they
didn't show you in Donnie Brasco but
they told you in the book was that
Donnie Brasco made a big raid in
Milwaukee before New York ah I just
didn't have enough time to put it in the
movie uh-huh he got the bow Asterius out
of Milwaukee or one of Minneapolis state
it's a mafia family that makes money on
a vending machines ah
I mean machine mafia family before he
busted the guys in New York he went to
Milwaukee so the first time I went to
Milwaukee in 99
those guys were getting out of jail oh
[ __ ] and the club is right across the
street from Italian they but they have a
little they got Italian even up yeah
it's a block so it goes this way and
Chinatown goes this way their version of
it's like two blocks
down Chinese right three or four
different Chinese restaurants a little
diner but that Italian block had a deli
you know the ones you walk in this light
cheese yeah
and they had meatball parlors for two
dollars what I mean nice nice one seem
ninety-nine you know I'm saying you you
were starving comic you find the place
that is 200 meatballs I'm me Paul
[ __ ] pong for $2 dollars not bad no
balls you know like it's a lot better to
[ __ ] the subway absolutely not least it
was real [ __ ] me absolutely the
prosciutto sandwiches meatball
sandwiches that are
I mean you know at certain places you
gotta pay in certain places you you you
you you it'll be worth it cuz it's it is
really good but a [ __ ] like like to
me I know that I know inflation has
changed but a true [ __ ] there's only
one place I know there's other places in
New York City but have you been in this
place in a story of Sal and Krishna you
know when you go back go to Sal and
Chris is in Astoria uuuugh you'll know
when you [ __ ] walk in from the smell
it's been there forever the [ __ ] I
mean it's like eight dollars for a
[ __ ] brick a brick like a [ __ ]
sandwich with the bread the meat
everything's fresh you buy a jar pepero
Sini's a sixteen ounce coke a bag of
wise potato chips who's gonna [ __ ]
stop you you read The Daily News while
you're eating nothing's gonna stop you
stop you nothing could stop you and that
truly is only in New York that what I
just described yes and it's only you
know it's in Queens but it's [ __ ]
well worth it it's well [ __ ] worth it
I was in New York City and I walked up
to Times Square last week and they got
like a [ __ ] Domino's Pizza something
I I'll never go in and don't never come
back ever
there's a [ __ ] what's that uh what's
the Italian place garden there's none
like two blocks up from Times Square so
all their musical I would stand out
there with a rifle
people off as they went in there ever
why are you going in new year in New
York four years ago I'm in Long Island
staying right across the street from the
National Coliseum there's a hotel there
I'm going downstairs and I'm like my
glass is a smoking job when I get back
on the [ __ ] elevator two white kids
and that [ __ ] white father scotch on
Bob Lowe's pizza I wanted to punch the
would do it they don't know better and
go you know where you are
yeah you're in the heart of pizza and
you're getting Domino's just go anywhere
you're better than Domino's personally
[ __ ] insulting me yeah give
personally [ __ ] insult your in New
York
there's Pete's even the [ __ ] pizzas
better than Domino's I 99-cent slice
period Domino's I would go to anywhere
and slice before I go to [ __ ]
dominoes in New York anywhere that's
just really that's breach of treason
Domino's for desperation times
desperation hour and even then you eat
it and you feel bad if you feel bad you
regret but it's desperate which like
last choice tale Mary [ __ ] if you're in
[ __ ] Columbus Ohio or something and
everything is closed that [ __ ]
dominoes and you're starving after a
show and it's quick the quickest way
they deliver you give the guy in extra
tenth is you don't give a [ __ ] you run
it to your room and that 145 right to
the room that's the at one time I either
I got a thin cheese and I ain't half and
read my through the other half out and
that went back in the garbage and took
back out but you knew you were gonna you
know you own all the way you thought it
was gonna disappear it started some
nights after issue you gotta [ __ ]
know Thursday night yeah but to switch
it from food I want to talk to you about
some because I want to see your take on
it
Jessie's smell it last week this [ __ ]
guy's a clown he's a [ __ ] clown he
listen Joey first I thought this is what
I thought it was and we've all been a
part of him
okay I thought and I'll be totally
honest my wife when it first happened
she said I think this is [ __ ] just
win at first I was like when I first
happened I looked at his face when it's
very first taxing something's not right
I didn't think that I didn't think I
thought something wasn't right about his
face my wife said I think this is some
[ __ ] I was like really she goes yeah
I'm telling you I didn't think that but
because she said that I just kind of
going without
yeah yeah this is some [ __ ] I just
was kind of like you know raised it like
being contrarian I thought it was a
dicksuck gone wrong Joe we've all been a
part of dick-suck gun world it has
nothing to do with his sexuality he's
homosexual I don't care about that
men women straight gay we've all been a
part of a dicksuck gone wrong meaning
you with a girl
you thought one thing she thought
another thing maybe there was a dicksuck
maybe you thought you were gonna get a
dicksuck reciprocated something was
boyfriend locks on the door there's many
different things that could happen in a
dick sock and that's just they that's
just uh I'm using dick suck as a
metaphor that's what I thought it was
and maybe he got pushed around smacked
around that's what I thought it was a
meeting it was a meetup gone wrong then
again nothing to do with his sexuality
you got all you got a preface at nine
times but to find out that it's this
[ __ ] with the Nigerian brothers who are
also brothers and then to find out that
there's charges and then there's charges
dropped and this [ __ ] guy is showing
up to court like he's [ __ ] a Russell
Westbrook all dressed to the [ __ ]
nines and he stood like he's going to
the playoffs in [ __ ] like he's going to
the game for the fan be a finalist
[ __ ] dressed and he's still acting
like he did nothing wrong
[ __ ] we know you did so this is
you think that people it's like oj not
to secede and kill anybody but it's like
what about the two people that attacked
you you don't care about them there's
two mega people in Chicago with their
[ __ ] beats and no disrespect to
Chicago
that ain't pizza no disrespect but
there's two magog eyes homo homophobic
race ik racist mad guys running in the
streets of Chicago Jesse don't you want
to catch the [ __ ] guys at assaulted
you since it's not the Nigeria and now
they're saying the Nigerians might have
been wearing white face so black face a
white face is the new black face in 2019
per this [ __ ] cup this guy's a clown
did you see Chris Rock rip his [ __ ]
yeah yeah good job I just want to know
like I saw his face I saw a little blue
you mean you saw his face that night and
I go son
it's not right completely no they didn't
beat him up enough to put the noose over
his head exact I just had ideas I've
seen people get mugged you know I've
been there with people who got mugged
I see the people the animals I've been
with and I've even had to look at them
and go Jesus Christ you know okay let's
take all that [ __ ] out but I knew some
then one two days I didn't pay much
attention to it I don't pay a dime in on
it from the beginning then two or three
days later I found that he didn't give
him the phone now I knew something was
wrong
I didn't know what it was I'm not gonna
sit here and tell you I know what he did
but I know this is not right well
there's incriminate pictures knows
whatever I know if I get beat up the
console on my phone I give him the phone
just to see what the phone calls it was
managed the cops are gonna find out
anyway Joe let me be transparent about
something you noticed I was five minutes
late when I got here
it's supposed to be 11:30 yeah kinda at
11:35 I had to take a [ __ ] okay now I
have ulcerative colitis I think we
talked about this a lot but I have no
problem [ __ ] in public if I have to
go I gotta go all sort of colitis look
it up I'm not gonna describe my disease
but if I have to go I have to go I don't
know your neighborhood good where we
shoot the show here okay I'm driving
around III don't feel comfortable
because I I said I'm gonna wind up
[ __ ] in public in this neighborhood
and it's gonna be on surveillance that's
my biggest fear
now of course I would love to find a
bathroom at Denny's the carwash where I
never I drove around looking to [ __ ] in
public find a corner and alley but I
didn't feel comfortable cause I kept
seeing the cameras and all the stuff now
I'm not gonna I have a three point
system I go against the wall I use my
car so the three point system is I can
only be seen from one two or three cuz I
backed myself into a corner against the
wall if I have to [ __ ] in public I
couldn't find a place you have toilet
paper in your car prepared
I got a tall young mcdonald bag no
because i [ __ ] i [ __ ] right on the
street
hmm I loved it I saw that I thought that
I was the only sad Savage
no he's our neighbor so I never believed
Enfield's
your neighbor cuz my biggest fear is oh
there's Michael Rapaport [ __ ] in
public
oh no they'll take a picture sell to TMZ
and you're done
there's not I mean you could do way
worse things but there's heart it's hard
to come back from [ __ ] in public
like you're you're a [ __ ] dog so I am
I found the car wash a little car wash
up the street I went and bought a water
did my business came in I was five
minutes late I pride myself on being
early cuz I had parked down the street
before and then as I had to [ __ ] I said
I don't think there's a bathroom in
Joe's spot and I don't want to blow up
Joe's spot the point is is Joe is
anywhere in the world okay we're in the
valley here this is a residential
neighborhood if if I'm concerned about
being caught on video tape for [ __ ]
in public and I know I could have been
caught on videotape for [ __ ] in
public there's no video tape downtown
Chicago in the middle of [ __ ] did
people know where he got this happened
this is downtown Chicago this isn't some
[ __ ] discreet a suburban neighborhood
this is in the middle of [ __ ] Chicago
there's no video tape of anything except
for a one photo of two guys covered
there's no video tape of it and the
whole time when he's walking to his
house from his house they're kicking
them they're beating or putting a noose
bleech there's no video tape up in no
surveillance video and I can't take a
[ __ ] on the way to do the Church of
what's happening now get the [ __ ] out of
here and also like you said if you and
Lee jumped me right now and you're
kicking me and beating me and all his
[ __ ] and and and on top of that you put
a [ __ ] noose on my neck that's a
fight for your life that ain't just a
little you'll give me your wallet to get
son to actually get a noose on someone's
neck you too guys that's a fight for my
[ __ ] life I'm not gonna have just a
little scratch attack and he said they
were kicking him in his back let me see
your back let me see the [ __ ] boot
wounds it's [ __ ] did they ever has
come like explain why like weren't
weren't the brothers on the show with
him and didn't he pay them with a check
yeah did anyone ever come at like this
thing it did saying over in the police
and listen police a furious in the area
the eye is gonna get him and if he's if
he's lucky if that [ __ ] kid is in
Chicago and he's in a 25 mile per hour
speeding zone he goes 26 he's getting
arrested he's not welcome in Chicago
ever again he better be careful in
Chicago because he made [ __ ] everybody
look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] now I heard
that he's friends with Obama's assistant
apparently that's how many kinds of
system made the call apparently that's
what happened
I'm not mad because hey you know what
the brothers got to win every once in a
while too I drafted up the ass
constantly you got to give a window but
it's an irresponsible irresponsible
[ __ ] thing to I mean and well how
sick are you like you're on a TV show
you've never done anything before you're
this is like the best first job ever
like starting a career as an actor
you're young openly gay good-looking kid
black kid on a successful show you
you're not gonna ask for a better start
to a career to be a supporting character
on Empire
how much more Fame do you need like
right now like this I'm the baby said
I'm the gay to pop get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ]
everybody's a freedom fighter
everybody's you know [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out my do you realize where we live
and how you and I grew up compared to
where we live it's all [ __ ] different
okay look it let's start with never mind
[ __ ] Jesse stand wet let's talk about
Harvey let's talk about Marilyn Monroe
let's talk about never never [ __ ]
land mmm let's talk about you know Cosby
that you know we were talking about this
couple of weeks ago so Cosby raped let's
say ten chicks in this trail at NBC
let's just say right nobody saw how much
do I have to pay you for you to walk out
for me to walk out with a chick that's
half [ __ ] in gaad's up a shirt might
be able to the button might be off she
might be holding her shoes
nobody's seen none of these things so
was it NBC that's playing I'm just using
MBC as an example
I'm up with MBC down somebody had to see
something in 20 [ __ ] years
absolutely okay somebody saw something
somebody knew something you know Harvey
Weinstein these agents were sending
people yes it was well-known yes and a
lot of chicks did suck his dick that's
sure you know this never never went this
[ __ ] guy I saw you comment about on
Twitter and I made my comments about but
again everybody's blaming the parents
never Neverland you never lived in
Hollywood you've never been caught up in
Hollywood yeah to be who else there are
people that don't make $65,000 a year in
this country right there short of that
by the 40 grand fifty grand a [ __ ]
year compared to what this kids making
an episode yeah only in Hollywood would
you're thinking take you that place yeah
absolutely okay I'm not now he's a
[ __ ] junkie too is that yeah let's
get this on yeah yeah yeah so when you
add drugs to the Miss mix you're not
thinking the same I give him all these
benefits of doubts that when you're
doing drugs he was saying he was doing a
lot of ecstasy and he was copping XE
from the two Nigerians and all this [ __ ]
you know it's like I mean you do coke
the next day it's tough to do stand-up
you're not connected to your material
you just up there reading a [ __ ]
script from that you have in your mind
so I gotta give them all these things
you know but what makes you say 65 Jesus
is enough I want to stick out right it's
not you know I'm not gay enough I'm not
black enough right I need to stick out
you so even more these are all things
that are associated with the lifestyle
that surrounded us yeah this is what's
around us you could go nuts on the shy I
will tell you this honestly I dealt with
criminals for 20 years that I have more
faith in than the people I'm surrounded
with today because there's faith amongst
thieves these people come up to you look
at your favorite or bar and then you
know man we loved your Netflix passion
and two weeks later somebody comes up to
you and you weren't there these three
idiots are saying and you thought you
can't call them out because we people
like you and I go to jail here
see people like you and I were raised to
call him somebody confront them and say
did you really say this no yeah well Bob
whatever if you do this here you're hard
to work with
yeah difficult to work with your
whatever you know you're all these
things yeah which anywhere else people
would talk to you know you know what I
[ __ ] up Mike right never happen again
right I was thinking you know at least
you know where I stand here you don't
know where you stand
no and you they're in a business to rob
you if you don't watch your [ __ ]
you'll get rod right there Rob right
keep putting [ __ ] on you in Bates and
you know this club is that a seven
dollar surcharge to your ticket so for
every ticket I sell I gotta give you $7
off the top is that is that some
[ __ ] that happens oh no what happens
I don't mind you getting a seven off the
top but split it with Uncle Joe right
let me know if you don't do nothing that
even if you give me 90 percent of the
[ __ ] door and I sell 1500 seats you
get seven hundred seven dollars per
ticket you're robbing me right
the agents ain't saying that name you
know I'm saying cuz they don't want to
break that relationship they have a bomb
at them how do you find out about that
just go buy a ticket if you go buy one
just go buy a ticket someday just to
check it just go to or you go to one of
your tickets and buy a ticket what does
it call the surcharge a surcharge
everybody got them taking my step-mom
above a bar you know there's some clubs
you play that they want a house nut and
then per ticket it's 14 [ __ ] dollars
14 for the casino in Connecticut
what's 14 [ __ ] casino it's supposed
to be a write-off entertainment right
fourteen they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] they just want to [ __ ]
they just want to [ __ ] whoever they can
with you and I'm not complaining I'm not
mad I'm but just let me know to be in
this position to sell tickets in to go
out and to do comedy but we live in
Hollywood and you know we sit down we
watch never-never-land and you say how
can the [ __ ] parents see it
the
parents had nothing and next thing you
know they're standing next to Michael
Jackson I know look at the one family
let the money for a house right she said
it yeah it was a loan low interest yeah
then when they said don't worry about
it's a gift you know yeah you just get
caught up you know absolutely what I did
The Longest Yard I can't light anybody I
can't lie to you I got caught up how you
ever see a TV she would go to the taping
of a TV show and Lee walks in and says
is lying I'm here now it's a funny line
the first time but they make you do it
seven times
uh-huh the PAS are still giggling ah the
directors are still giggling directed
and the producers like that's a funny
line it's not really a funny [ __ ]
line but they're blowing smoke appear ah
to keep you fresh to keep you upbeat ah
the producers are both slow could be
asked to keep your freshen to be upbeat
and then you go see the final product
and you go what a piece of [ __ ] this ah
hey you know what I was shooting along
the shot they were telling me answer
that
there's that you're gonna do this you're
gonna blow up you don't do this
none of those things happened right and
I should have known but I got you you
know it's like it's n-c-double-a time of
the year I got you in somebody asked me
did you better bracket and I go I
haven't I
I respect college ball and the final
this time they're so much betting would
ruin it
I bet on the final four and I [ __ ]
got my ass handed to me you know this is
so pure and so American yeah just watch
it yeah watch where Michigan State
upsets Duke good you know and [ __ ] I
know you mean it's all about that's what
that's all about
I agree I love Boulder Colorado I love
Colorado you know what I'm gonna call
right on it because I [ __ ] on Colorado
what do you mean it's God's country I
got arrested there from kidnapping and I
pulled thousand scams there I got
divorced there I'm like Colorado down as
a human being yeah I go to Denver
Boulder those places I don't deserve to
be there mmm but I know there's going in
do you know I got you know this going
the [ __ ] I got you so I was telling
somebody that Billy so when was the last
time you been on college basketball
don't [ __ ] remind me that's not
[ __ ] college basketball I just wanna
I just cleaned up on the Super Ball
it was the killer bees my yeah yeah yeah
that's good yeah yeah yeah I took at the
Redskins yeah Redskins covered I think I
paid me that Monday and I take a [ __ ]
I take the bus to Port Authority I take
the hate train down and I go like 150
something Street and I'm walking around
it's January it's [ __ ] freezing I'm
walking around and I see this store that
sells chocolate I weed I knew they saw
it so honey 64th and Amsterdam and I
walk in there I buy I take a soda I take
a Daily News they only had three sodas
and they used to be health food stores
aha in the 80s they would call health
food store I and they sold the weed they
had one thing a protein powder one those
protein bars in the bars
well why here's something I got like a
milk yeah yeah yeah with the protein and
it was bulletproof glass and a little
skinny black guy I saw mr. Wendell
uh-huh like I caught me even buy them
this is a different time this is 93 when
I still went into that neighborhood to
buy weed but on this particular January
which was like February that they have
the soup oh it was freezing in New York
it's freezing
it's all January days don't [ __ ] win
this coming off the East River and the
home and it's just cold so I go in there
I buy the [ __ ] 20 sack i buy $60
worth of weed I bought three twenty
eight hundred from the Super Bowl I'm
living like a doctor I go in there let
me give me give me a quarter I go I take
it outside now I can't roll in there
right so I take it outside I go in the
building like other steps and I roll
enjoy and then like I do what every
other New Yorker does in nineteen
[ __ ] 83 I go for a [ __ ] walk and
I'm walking to smoking this [ __ ]
joint and the wind blew it out so now I
go into a building corner where the wind
can't get me and I go to light to join
this alright the Jonah here are you
serious get on the floor put your hands
behind you head I put my hands behind my
head I turned around it was a [ __ ]
mailman with the bag
he was really an undercover cop get on
the floor get on the floor holy [ __ ]
also the van pulled up here and a cop
cop up there Jesus crying walk get up
check for ID I had no idea in those days
I never can
mmm criminal I got cash in my pocket
rolling papers in the way that's all I
needed
I was that's your idea yeah well I
really know why am i driving I don't
know I don't have need to have a license
on well why am i driving they picked me
up
what are you doing Liz neighborhood I
said that was I came down here it's on
the Upper West Side this is the Upper
West Side 2:00 in the afternoon and the
guy goes to me get up he searches me he
goes if you have more than 10 singles in
your pocket and he goes in my pocket
well it's in my pocket his two 20s and
so all our bills he puts it back in my
pocket takes the [ __ ] bag of dope out
but he doesn't want to ask you either
with his name on it bro I come up in
take a [ __ ] walk listen I bought some
pot he didn't ask me where I bought the
pot or anything he took the other cop
the other cop him the mailman took his
shirt off and now that was two guys with
badges outside their shirts and
shouldn't had a van like a crime
something van and the guy goes uh
alright what's your name I told my name
he [ __ ] takes me into the van
handcuffed they take the handcuffs off
and I had to put my hand on something
and then all Senate came back Jose Diaz
been arrested he goes so you didn't lie
to us you cool were cool the reason why
we did this is because the school up the
block he's gonna be selling joints to
the kids up the school were saying about
the dollar what we're gonna do is this I
was so cool with the cops that cop took
the handcuffs off they open the bag of
dope they took half of it out threw it
in the floor and gave me the rest of it
back they go now we just gonna write you
a ticket
take the ticket I gonna take the ticket
they give me a ticket and I'm [ __ ] in
New York but I gotta go to court
guess what man I gotta go to court mmm
and see double a finals oh [ __ ] Houston
against [ __ ] North Carolina are you
serious Hughes's Valvano Houston's given
nine nine in the paper but the line goes
up to nine and a half so I love Houston
and I got in that December I went to by
Pat Benatar tickets at the [ __ ] giant
Stadium and
commotion and I turn around and it's
North Carolina State with JimBob and
walking through then I go what the [ __ ]
and that wasn't a sign like that should
have been my sign but I didn't let it I
went with the national public and I go
Houston's gonna slaughter them so I
think like 300 I call the book make and
I gotta go to court that night New York
had six o'clock Court six o'clock court
then I to the n-c-double-a finals I get
the letter in the mail you gotta go to
court at six o'clock and you get there
at six you could you know there's 80
people on the front pocket you're not
watching the game and there's no [ __ ]
there's no T DVR there's no sports
phones 35 minute 35 cents for the first
three minutes and you sit there they
always gave you your score last right
they give you the Islanders and the
Penguins and hockey they know what your
glascott ball and [ __ ] then they give
you college basketball on and the NC
double-a finals when they said North
Carolina was up by one
I just hung up the phone I'm like all I
could [ __ ] take it because you knew
you cuz you and you they weren't beating
the spray that won't beat the spread and
I remember getting out of there for the
second half like eight minutes left and
just running to a bar down by the court
that was read whatever totally second
where I had to go and I caught a [ __ ]
beatin and I'll never forget that
I heard the bookie so much [ __ ] money
like I was borrowing the bar we hung on
it there was a loanshark upstairs his
name was George and I would borrow money
from him but I would borrow from him for
Lee right so I would borrow five hundred
right it's not for me Lee got his
girlfriend pregnant he's embarrassed to
ask him he would never go up too late so
I wouldn't make payments for Lee uh-huh
has me uh then I would go up to the
final and make Michael Rapaport needs a
thousand eggs okay he [ __ ] up he
shattered someone's lawn and this I had
this guy like 12 account plus he would
give me $50 for everybody I bought I'm
gonna say so he gave me a tip for every
booth at human waste to get snow storm
so bad and daily news yeah do you
remember that yeah yeah yeah the
newspaper would not come and you
couldn't bet yeah so addicted I was
telling somebody's story I was so
addicted to gambling
corner I was call up and I will bet 40
time parlays everyman MB bettin MBA is
no bueno it's not good no it's the
quickest way to destruction you only met
the MBA in October that's it once the
lines get hard you're gonna lose all
your money and it's every day see
footballs on the weekends but basketball
is everyday you can bet Monday night
right so you're fighting every night but
I'm in where the one snowstorm we call
the booking like how you doing gray
Cavalier what's on the board today I'm
gonna say listen we got no lines the
newspapers didn't come ahh the only
lines we have it to some shitty game
that's what off already and then we got
like Harvard playing LaSalle uh-huh I
don't forget this Harvard was getting 32
points I mean my buddy's like world
ain't gonna get beat by 32 there's no
way they're gonna beat by 32 or taking
the [ __ ] we're taking Harvey we call
the guy we felt like I don't know how
much the housings out of Harvard well
[ __ ] sitting there waiting for
because there's no yes PN there's no
SportsCenter I think there was what
Center it but it wasn't what is it even
it wasn't as it tenses right now you
wouldn't get every score from every game
and I mean you're gonna remember this
I'll never forget what we're watching
worth its 11:20 we're at the bar we're
watching Eyewitness News and Austin
sports would Warner wolf and one of
course how you doing if you had it
Harvard in the 32 you're a loser
let go to the videotape that's what he
opened up with he goes if you had
Harvard in the 32 you're a loser tonight
we just looked at each other like god
dammit what a wolf is Paula's [ __ ]
loses you remember what a wolf that was
my god let's go to the videotape my god
what he he had that great voice oh my
god I'm on CBS he would come into the
knick games or something yeah I don't a
knick game and he goes oh look was in
the stands
his name was Warner wolf he goes that's
my brother werewolf it's a game yeah you
say he was crazy [ __ ] New York yeah
it's such a good voice yes he did water
wolf so what you went from went up in
February to down thousands by markes
oh I was I was down do you bet now on
the games though once in a great while
better you have seen mad
if I'm Vegas and it's gonna be but not
like you're not like in it once you lose
money and you see what gambling does to
people like I had a decision at the age
of eighteen nineteen I said I could
gamble with the rest of these [ __ ]
steps I could take that money and snort
coke hahaha what I rather do gamble or
something I can't control
or walk around and look out windows and
get my dick sucked I'll go a plan B
right like that was a [ __ ] that was
this the family was just there was no
Vegas always wins
I'm the I I never been into it sports
blackjack I just don't [ __ ] with like
you know every now and get then I'll
$100 on a thing my fantasy football but
even then it's it's reasonable like I
don't [ __ ] around with put my money and
because I just I don't get it
I don't [ __ ] with blackjack poker none
of that [ __ ] now everything from in
Vegas I'll play a $5 hand I'll go here's
$200 and I'll give myself to $200
[ __ ] limit and if I lose it 200 or I
make 60 bucks I like the money in my
pocket I had a roommate that at 19 what
up he was up 80 and next thing you know
I was down 60 he bet Miami
he took Miami and sound everybody's bets
and the killer bees lost and they had to
get two jobs three just 60 granny lost
60 grand
he lost 140 18 18 years old 19 years old
so he had a work of his father's deli
6:00 in the morning to two or three and
then he pump gas from four to twelve he
did that every day for eight months or
something to get out of debt
[ __ ] that he paid the guy every [ __ ]
Thursday together Jesus Christ they
negotiated something I think he got him
down to like 40 and he just went to work
I'm not sad he did two job and they sold
coke and now he's all [ __ ] up and I
remember being friends with him like now
with white friends on Facebook because
it was just too much wrong why he felt
like that we left them out
it ruined his [ __ ] life though he
never watched sports that was it he
never pulled out another sports channel
a guy was his brother's birthday
yesterday and I except his brother a
message and I asked him how he was doing
and he goes he's okay he's alive he's
got the hip [ __ ]
after that he you've got the junk and
[ __ ] rubber banja he got that backgammon
[ __ ] him up at 19 that was like a
wake-up call
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he never came back he
never recovered
I like the money in my [ __ ] pockets
Joe no I don't but you know who else it
was a degenerate gambler my mother
really baseball the Boston Red Sox and
those [ __ ] Mets took it to the
cleaners she was betting Boston never
losing she was in love with the red
science and the Mets [ __ ] - yeah and
when that [ __ ] wasn't good enough then
you got to go to hoe TB right then with
no TB and then by the time my mother
died my mother was getting home at 1:00
every night 2:30 cuz she go to Yonkers
when you go to Yonkers for the night
races that that's your warning that
you're a degenerate piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
do they still go on Yonkers they do
comedy at Yonkers Raceway there's no
there's no horses up there
Yonkers yeah Janka still has horses have
you ever done comedy up there no but
somebody told me when I was in New York
they do they have a night of dance at
the track
you could book it when you're in New
York can you imagine performing in front
of those [ __ ] I would do great it would
probably be fun know exactly how to get
off of course as I was one of those guys
of course you have to go up death row
and [ __ ] heat about gambling
you got Oh getting your dick sucked I
mean I still remember going to the
Meadowlands when the Pegasus was
upstairs my buddy was like a chef
upstairs we had to wear a jacket to go
up but I still don't look going to metal
hands in 93 my buddy was a degenerate
horse guy and I'm going because we go to
Harlem first buy a bag of coke then go
to the track and we would go to a race
track and in between races you go to the
stairway is it the Meadowlands you have
you've been that and it [ __ ] no it's
like a [ __ ] shooting gallery
I mean people smoking reefer people
smoking crack people doing lines reckon
be is this
even hookers out there they even have we
went to school with a girl from dead now
god rest her soul she [ __ ] she had
the hip - and she died in the car we
grew up with her and she was 93 she got
really sick she was hot growing up but
to him she already had the hip and she
was smoking crack and but we would see
her hooking at the track and we would
all like be talking we go this Cathy and
we'd all [ __ ] Tarin
she's my back since she would walk by
because not she jump on you and Lee
Chandi and ask you stupid questions
while I borrow ten bucks
[ __ ] out here Cathy I went out there to
see I went out to the Meadowlands to see
like Michael Spinks fight somebody like
hit man or hit man fight somebody on her
when they used to fight on short circuit
go out to the track not then seen the
tremendous fistfight under the TV like
two guys Oh all real fight oh yeah just
blast of each other at the Meadowlands
house I saw tremendous fistfight ad and
OTB on 78th Street at the Port Authority
mmm at the Oh TV's I used to come out
and I would take the [ __ ] bus over
think Fort Lee and then come out and go
there and I would always put like two
dolls on a horse so I'm walking there to
kill time I saw them blasting each other
in there one day - a good Jenner of
[ __ ] game you know it's one thing to
bet on baseball basketball football but
to bet on horses to me is even the mole
it's even way out there like you know
how the [ __ ] do you know how that horse
is feeling how do you know IIIi don't
understand that [ __ ] like when people
put big money on horse betting that's
crazy
dirty business well I was growing up we
realized that you had a bet on a horse
that was getting shot with his potato
after you get on with a steroid a horse
if a horse bleeds from his nose he's
good to go heat they have to give him a
shot to stop the bleeding but at the
Meadowlands in those days like seven out
of the ten races were won by those
horses that would get no shots of that
medication I got you and they had a note
at the bottom
and then you know trainers write other
people know trainers you get calls and
trainers people tell you I got a tip
from this guy right so there's all these
tips but this is the way I look at like
right now my buddy owns a sports betting
service and I look at it this way let me
tell you something Michael Jordan was
betting on his own game to losing arch
sleepster went down the drain Pete Rose
went out of Pete Rose's bet in baseball
that's right yeah knowing the [ __ ] he
was doing while he was coaching and he's
Pete Rose nobody could call it you have
no [ __ ] clue no clue that's why when
somebody calls you and says thank you
things online for 10 [ __ ] out here it's
it's impossible it might happen one day
it might happen - it might even happen
but then you're gonna get hands and
knees right at Easter day oh that kid
that got hooked
I'm betting yeah yeah he got hooked on
bet it he was hanging hours he was doing
drugs like rolling [ __ ] joints and
doing quaaludes and one man he throws a
Puerto Rican kid I love the Brahma he
goes hey what the [ __ ] is it that you
guys always talk about like what do you
guys always talking about gambling how
do you get into this [ __ ] I talk about
wine it's like all of us who I had a bar
we're talking about lines and hi you bet
he goes maybe I'll put a bed in this
weekend so that Sunday I was little
little he was my roommate and he goes
let's call mr. agent put it better and
we [ __ ] call mr. age he put in a
hundred time parlay do you understand
what does that mean that means that two
teams gotta win I think it pays like a
ten team to team a five time parlay and
70 they lose 30
uh-huh 140 lose 60 ah is it you know so
they go up like that yeah he bet $100 a
hundred time Paula Jesus so he was gonna
win some dough that was his first better
because I'm looking to make some money
I'm gonna bet upon light which the years
way that finally there's a sucker's bet
it's a sucker's bet you have to take one
team and better all you got on it if you
take let's say in college football
if you bet the number one team the whole
season you're gonna be 82 right you
gonna have six net winners right if you
bet 200 you're gonna make 1200 and then
you retire for the [ __ ] year
sit the [ __ ] down smart gambling right
they want you to met parlays they love
teases they love when you the hablar and
if eight time T's a good luck good luck
when you give the other team ten points
does there's teasers that you got to
pick three teams but you could also
delegate ten points if I'm giving you
one
now I'm getting nine mm-hmm you know I'm
saying like they're so [ __ ] weird all
that [ __ ] I don't like so he that's how
they [ __ ] you you bet the parlay the
first game he had won outright and the
second game it was Pittsburgh and
Seattle and Pittsburgh was winning at
the end of the first call at 27 he bet
he bet Seattle Pittsburgh was beating
them 27 nothing at the end of the first
quarter and we all passed out you know
Seattle came back and beat him 28 20 27
and he won that parlay my friend's dad
called him and said if you want to pick
up the money he could go pick it up
tonight
so that Sunday we went down there we
picked up the money and he goes I want
to go to the fanciest restaurant where
he'd go to and we went to this place in
the fall he called pick a Lisa more
around the Hudson River where Jackie
Gleason you saw buildings by the word
Palace and amusement parks I thrown out
torn down and he [ __ ] him what I'll
never forget this place had lobster Fra
Diavolo
and he'd [ __ ] put his finger hose
that Joe that was a Comedy Store
here-here ate the lobster and he ran out
of water and he drank the finger ball he
had never been in the fancy rest
Illmatic the finger ball and he drank
everybody looked at him at the table but
that's how they hooked them you know
they give you a hook when you gamble
they give you a hook first and let you
win a couple times it's not them it's
the universe it always happens it's the
universe and that's how you get hooked
that's how you get home you think you
figure it out now you figured it out and
once you got it figured out that's when
they gay
and it's a slow process and then in 93
when I got divorced I had the gall to
work for a sports betting service in
Boulder
guys out of Long Island it's to find her
and all those guys the people AJ Benza
used to work yeah yeah yeah yeah so I
went to work for their partner in
bowling and that's where I learned even
more about gambling and the level of the
degenerate it's almost as bad as the
junkie mm-hmm like business guys
business guy a CEO of companies calling
you for information and they've used so
much money on their credit cards that
now they're using the receptionist
credit card so their wives don't find
that it was crazy it was what I learned
then about gambling you really shut me
down to gambling
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and that's why I don't
like when we used to do a couple of
years ago we used to pick this [ __ ] like
that and we lost like six weeks in Iran
I know I don't want to do it and you
know what else I don't like about it I
don't want to encourage people to do it
because it's a bad habit ticketing then
you'll never get out of it the only way
to get out of it is by Oland by losing
your house by losing [ __ ] you know all
those vices they always get you at the
end
I like the [ __ ] little [ __ ]
fantasy bats this that you but I I like
it if it's if it's responsible if it's
fun but I don't have that that gene -
just keep going keep going
I don't have that maybe the head it had
I like my $200 off [ __ ] I lost $200 I
mean that's my that's me yeah except for
this year in fantasy football I did win
one league and I fought them real nice
but that's again there's a there's a
there's an end to it do you do anything
else for adrenaline because like I used
to I used to gamble not big money but a
lot and even when you're up like you
should walk away and you just can't you
know I'm up I'm gonna keep going up
it's rental in real life oh I mean if
there's anything else that you do that
like because that that gave me
such a rush that it was hard I gotta say
stand-up gives you an adrenaline yeah
III feel the adrenaline which would
stand up and which is a new and new
thing but I like it
I haven't gambled since I started doing
sin though at all no I probably stopped
me have no choice he couldn't I was
terribly good winning Sin City you [ __ ]
you could give him a winner right you
could give him a winner and he'd [ __ ] it
up you picked the right never saw
anything like it in my life
you could give him a winner and he would
pick something that you're like why
would you pick that like you don't know
nothing about this person he's a bad
gambler really bad Ike I never saw
anything like it
I like I will pick one that's baggy $7
$8 right you wasting my time you waste
in that time right if you're gonna hit
him hit him
you know wasted seven dollars seven
hours into seven dollars or some he had
seven left on the [ __ ] third-grader
dollars you gotta enema
you gotta hit him - that's real
adrenaline yeah that's really [ __ ] that
you want to throw your TV out the window
that's real adrenaline that's why you're
gonna go go if you're gonna get involved
with that [ __ ] go like how would I get
involved I go like because it's gambling
I can't watch a whole sporting event
because of my experience of pts now you
can't just to watch I'll watch you'll
pick one pick one out if I gotta go to
the comic store at 9:30 and there's an
MBA game on I watch six minutes of it to
watch their offense how they're playing
defense once I see [ __ ] [ __ ]
basketball it's over like it's all I
just switch it right once I see what I
think I am old school Bob Cousy I like
setups I like passes I like one guy
that's outstanding
that's basket I don't like [ __ ]
Giacomo Joe [ __ ] yeah come on Joe just
for [ __ ] some guys running in gonna roll
the center is driving that no that's
what I said I hear you I could MBA to me
now when I watch the NBA I love the guy
you said
Westbrook because he yells at people
he's so intense he when he told that kid
he told the parents to [ __ ] not touch
him and then he yelled at another fan I
like all that [ __ ] I like I can't watch
the Lakers I saw you on one of those TV
shows
kill him saying if the Lakers don't go
to the playoffs I think you're right the
Lakers got duped with LeBron James I
think he suckered them I think he came
here just to produce TV shows
that's it I agree he just duped them I
mean you know you can't count they're
unwatchable oh they're on watching yeah
they are unlocked they need a [ __ ]
done watch if they need a refurbish the
Lakers are unwatchable even with LeBron
James something is not right no when you
watch me like this [ __ ] clunky yeah
they gotta start from scratch
LeBron's got LeBron you're gonna stay
here you're the anchor everybody else is
going I don't came up for free agency
one day he's 180 years old he gotta go
to to keep every the only one I like is
Kuzma was Kuzma kyle Kuzma he's good a
white guy would it be it no he's half
black half Mexican that's a guy that's
the guy he's good he's good
pretty boy yeah yeah he could play and
he got [ __ ] balls but they look
clunky [ __ ] kidnap them the whole
season yeah they're horrible to watch
horrible to watch I like the art of
basket yeah I like the art of basketball
I like that guy that's in the paint and
also he pops not that guy at the
baseline yeah three footer that shows
that's the rockin boys the [ __ ] ball
move the ball that's why I enjoy college
basket yeah at this level like I told my
wife Dee and I were watching Friday we
got back from Dumbo and we were watching
Virginia from Brooklyn No Dumbo [ __ ]
the movies oh uh we're watching The
Virginian attacked against yeah yeah
yeah well they blew the game against
Duke at the Last Stand I had him he had
the [ __ ] thing but before that there
was a game me and my wife would take
that [ __ ] off the saint college
basketball this is running gun [ __ ] yeah
no but nobody's you nobody's paying
attention this guy's just trying to
[ __ ] score points all that [ __ ]
I can't why I hear you but I love old
school basketball you know I told Lee
that like I never really was a Shaq fan
by the chakra at all I come from the
eighties when all those centers would
have beat the [ __ ] out of shot he would
have given it to zone but bro listen he
went up against Hakeem Olajuwon when he
was 37 years old
Hakeem was already old he was [ __ ]
Shaq he [ __ ] shack up he [ __ ] shack
up so much they swept him for [ __ ]
games Hakeem was in a complete different
league and nobody ever saw that I keep
my forgot about that like when I saw
that Shaq was done with me he was a
beat-up old man he was dirty [ __ ]
seven years old he did some crazy [ __ ]
the Shaq he embarrassed him to the
[ __ ] T and then the next year they
made him awaken and it was forgotten
about well I didn't forget about that I
never forgot about that I know for a
fact they've towns would have beat him
to a pulp at six foot nine I would have
[ __ ] know
Dave count he wouldn't Shaq would have
eaten date calendar oh [ __ ] he would
have been it he would have been the
prosciutto sandwich we just talked to
listen to me they've come with six nine
chef would have had his [ __ ] ballsack
six on his head but six nine white Irish
and tough you got to shoot him with a
bazooka to 210 pounds AK was 300 pounds
lean with a [ __ ] school shacks Moses
would have picked up Shaq I love slams
nine lamb Jim this is what guys and I
know a lot of people are sitting home
we'll enjoy you're out of your mind but
I want to see Moses Malone Moses Moses
led the league in scoring and was number
two in rebounding okay 20 rebounds a
[ __ ] game in 1980 [ __ ] three who
and one with the Houston [ __ ] to go
check the [ __ ] stats see how many 20
[ __ ] rebound seasons Shaq listen no
disrespect to the late great Moses
Malone I'm with you Shaq would have had
him he'd have had him in his pocket like
a little dog yes oh yes Moses would have
killed yes Moses would have killed Shaq
Moses with a kill shot I love modally
great Moses Malone what was this wood
that Moses with a kill Shaq there's a
couple there's Shaq would he he would
Dave Cowens that
not bill wall because he was a half a
fruitcake look a little warm [ __ ] him
shap woulda jumped on him Shaq would not
have [ __ ] with Kareem Kareem would have
been a problem or fan somebody broke his
Kareem will give you 40 but Kareem will
give you 40 and carry him off the floor
beating yes and over your body and [ __ ]
nobody remembers [ __ ] October 78 Kent
Benson opening season game Milwaukee
Bucks against the Lakers he made a
little mistake elbow and [ __ ] no that
was after he did the karate movie to
which I didn't understand why would you
elbow Kareem and you saw him fight Bruce
Lee
you already saw it we already saw it
this was after we already saw anybody
anybody who's ever heard anything about
Kareem ever Kareem is not a nice person
no he's a prick he's a prick I've always
had good relationships with Kareem I've
seen him over the years but his
reputation is that he's just not nice
not nice very uh my uncle my uncle
bought him out of Hong Kong awkward guy
too
awkward awkward but I think he would
have killed Shaq
I think Willis Reed with a [ __ ] Shaq up
cuz Willis Reed wouldn't let him in the
paint Willis Reed him with it annoying
him and then dollar bill would have been
over there [ __ ] with him a little bit
[ __ ] Shaq didn't have the [ __ ] Beast
he's a beast but it was a beast against
nobody I don't agree the beast against
nobody who was the toughest guys ever
cover me it's not like Shaq just playin
he had Dikembe Mutombo the Kevin matumbo
was terrible he's [ __ ] terrible can
you kid dikembe mutombo they beat the
[ __ ] out of them didn't your Nets the
New Jersey [ __ ] Nets with Jason Kidd
he had [ __ ] no and dick Dikembe
Mutombo when he was on the Sixers
he almost broke his [ __ ] on Dunkin
on'em arm he was horrible
he was horrible he came in with Thomas
he had no sentence - I grew up with Wes
Unseld I grew up with Bob Lanier
he would have lost when he ran well son
self with [ __ ] I still remember
[ __ ] Bernard King thrown the ball at
Bob Lanier when they during the game
just threw the ball on his chest to some
[ __ ] and Bob Lanier looking with a size
26 sneakers anybody stuck his foot up
his hand stuck his foot up is that I
think so many centers that I grew up
with with a kill shaft just
mentally mentally he was he was a fruit
check hadn't check had nobody covenant
nobody I do [ __ ] centers yeah he
[ __ ] Patrick Ewing Alonzo Mourning did
she can't owned all them 101 over 80
you know the Patrick Ewing [ __ ] his
first when he was able there his first
game at the garden with Patrick with
when he came into lead yeah
how old was go no magic who is it good
to go I don't know the dates I know they
were all no he only old man he wound up
on was [ __ ] that African from the
Houston Rockets he schooled him his
rookie and it was a school schooled him
his rookie and it was embarrassing he
did some crazy [ __ ] to see she don't
wakes up a little night shadow David
Robertson he owned a promise it was a
pan he [ __ ] had calm like it was this
little dog babysitter let me tell you
some David Ross this babysitter with his
Navy [ __ ] and all that [ __ ] was
little baby in his muscles yeah I
couldn't be with Carl Malone though he
owned Carl Malone and Carmel owns a have
you ever seen Carmel in your life yeah
so caramel oh [ __ ] yeah he's the size of
your [ __ ] door I just saw Carmel a
wild card Boxing he was there hanging
out do yo Kharma loan has been out of
the league now what almost 20 years he's
you don't want any problems with him
still he's a [ __ ] Savage he had him
like it was his like it was his like it
was it would lose a pet like was a
gerbil you know he reminds me of Carmel
of I'm Shaq Shaq reminds me and I love
this guy I loved him I got to meet him
him his game wasn't my type of game but
I really liked him he was a colorful guy
God rest his soul Darryl Dawkins yes
Darryl Dawkins was a [ __ ] I showed
this guy and somebody else the other day
when Darryl hit Doug Collins in the face
in the 76 finals vs. uh Maurice Lucas
yeah they were [ __ ] then then they
were squared off in the middle of it
like doing this what I always was a Bill
Walton fan he was good love bill warm
until Game six versus six is Julia
slammed on his face
he called the offensive foul Mike you're
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] he dunked it on his
[ __ ] whole family
he thought every time they don't even
tomahawk [ __ ] I'll never even go to
Philly no woman will never even go to
Philly that debt cuz julius erving
decided you know what we're gonna lose
but I got something for your [ __ ] it I
got something for your ass your white
little hippie friends I got something
for you [ __ ] a Grateful Dead a stropping
[ __ ] and dog he took him one our
war then walked what was he thinking
wall is like I'll be up with him what
dr. JK caught him on that break oh
that's a video oh he had that [ __ ] like
this and he dunked it like was a nerf
ooh like I was tremendous he had that
[ __ ] [ __ ] right here he's [ __ ]
like it's like he went like you [ __ ] and
he slammed it if you watched the footage
after that don't walk runs to the ref it
starts going on offensive ah that's not
offensive he dunked on your family your
[ __ ] whole family your all your kid
with your kids or PTSD that's why Lucas
can coach this year right every time he
season slam Jesus had Julian yeah a
genetical are they gonna get rid of Luke
yeah LeBron he ruined he here he's this
yeah he's gonna I didn't know I just
work here that's like you saying oh yeah
I got rid of Lee I behind legit I just
got a new guy in here there's Billy so
are we gonna find Luke definitely
definitely they wanted to fire an
earlier in the season like I said I
watched him he tried to he tried to take
over the Lakers he tried to get Anthony
Davis traded his best friend is Anthony
Davis's agent they had a whole [ __ ]
plan in store people think that I have
some personal vendetta against LeBron
listen in real life they say oh he's a
Greek I know he's a great guy yeah this
isn't about I'm talking about the the
character LeBron James the chosen one
the goat a King James I'm not talking
about the person this isn't I'm a fan I
I don't understand what sports you
everybody understood why you would hate
Derek Jeter you get it either you love
him or you're on the opposite teams
Tom Brady to this day either you love
the Patriots or [ __ ] Botox Brady
Kobe Bryant can't stand Kobe Bryant or
you love Kobe
for some reason with LeBron James you're
a hater you're a hater this guy tried to
take over the Lakers he told Anthony
Davis asked for a trade
we'll get your to the Lakers and then
we're gonna make our run for the
championship that didn't [ __ ] happen
[ __ ]
they've been on Luke Waltons ass all
[ __ ] season he wanted to get him
[ __ ] fired
it's been a disaster then he got his
injury he gets an injury sits on I think
it was 19 games instead of just being
injured like everybody else his his
physical therapist puts out a tweet you
guys have no idea what kind of pain pain
pain he suffered with what about Russell
what about Paul George when he broke his
[ __ ] leg in half Gordon Hayward from
the Celtics they broke their legs in
half their physical therapist didn't put
out what kind of suffering do you think
that was Paul George leg didn't just
break the [ __ ] thing broken half his
physical therapist didn't put on he's
just he's just trying to control every
[ __ ] narrative it he claimed he's the
goat you're not the [ __ ] goat get the
[ __ ] out of here
you're the goat the [ __ ] out of here
who's the goat Michael [ __ ] Jordan's
the gold period period come on man you
can talk all this she's your second
favorite my favorite players are it is
Michael Jordan I mean I didn't even like
hated Michael Jordan when he played I
was in Knicks fan in the 90s you think I
was sitting there celebrating when he
was [ __ ] us year after year after
year after year ft I hated that
[ __ ]
no I loved him and I wasn't blind and I
enjoyed it and I was there in North
Carolina when I was Joanna I loved until
it became my problem at a certain point
it became my problem I loved it when he
first got in the league but when it
became a problem where the Knicks were
not getting anywhere because of this
[ __ ] then it would then it was
started to come hate so I I had a period
of time like everybody else like Mike if
I could believe in Mike I mean running
around the city to get those [ __ ]
sneakers like a crazy person this was a
different time so I can't even say
Michael Jordan is one of my favorites I
say he's the greatest player but my
favorite my favorite players of all time
I did my top five I would go Julius
Erving Magic Johnson Isiah Thomas Moses
Malone Bernard
as far as my favorite players of that
era we're in agreeance on three of those
yeah it's Moses Julius the wealthy or no
our dark King was one of my all-time
favorites I mean it was a darken it was
lightning in a bottle guard open I felt
but I open up a can of whoop-ass I'm
Michael at the garden his rookie you
couldn't start him you couldn't stop my
Bernard king or king beautiful for
people everybody knows that people
didn't know who brother Bernard is watch
his old footage
unstoppable unstop you know you could
compare it to is a different style of
play but but in terms of like cuz Kevin
Durant is is like an old-school scorer
Kevin Durant is like a guy who you're
gonna get 30 and Knight Bernard you're
gonna get 30 you might get 50 you might
get 60 yeah and and and you might not
even like Bernard there's no dunks
there's like Kevin to right there's no
dunks there's no highlights and you
might get something every now and then
but but like Bernard his sixty point
games there's no oh [ __ ] did you see
that play it's just that's sixty points
you're not stopping Bernard King Kevin
Durant you're not stopping him he's like
like George Gervin he got fifty make it
look easy there's no you know [ __ ]
don't get on your [ __ ] family no
crazy crossovers just basket after
basket after basket and Bernard during
his run with the Knicks even when he was
with the Golden State Warriors when he
wasn't [ __ ] whacked out of his tree
on coke but that run with the Knicks yo
that was a tremendous 60 50 40 337 what
60 on the Celtics yo [ __ ] was broken
fingers broken fingers issues he was he
was uh they shipped him out he was the
comeback player of the year cuz he was
whacked out on the book of sugar and
then he came to Jersey he lived in North
Bergen and they caught him a North
Bergen one night with him passed out
with the coke on the t-shirt oh now and
then we used to we heard a rumor and we
were in the seventh and eighth grade me
and my friends heard a rumor that
Bernard King will practice at midnight
and Hudson County Park are you serious
did you see him listen to me so me
Chucky's McGrane who's the coach of
Ramapo today his brother why the old
Donald and this kid Bryan Smyth we wall
basketball horse we went up there within
the weeds
we waited the bushes for brother Bernard
midnight no lights only bask only the
moonlight are you [ __ ] kidding me
no eighth-grade King comes up get the
[ __ ] out of here when he was with the
Nets he was at the neck saw that that's
one of us he starts shooting he starts
playing we come out of the weeds like we
[ __ ] like we're [ __ ] homeless and
he goes what are you guys doing up him
nah we came to shoot with you and then I
first see he was apprehensive we played
three on three with Bernard King 1:00 in
the morning 1:30 in the [ __ ] morning
playing [ __ ] 300 basketball brother
Bernard came that's dope riots Mike was
covered on the Brian smite thumbs up on
Iowa football and drop that now he's a
stagehand ah good morning Americans Ben
this is Jesus by Chicago Brian smite was
covering up Bernard King went to Spenny
Brian went to steal the ball he broke
Brian smart nose Brian why are you
trying to steal a ball from Bernard King
Brian it was a crazy idea
we drove right into the hospital Willis
are you serious then we went to the
diner run by the hospital is a little
diner next to the north hudson valley
hospital and we went to a diner hate
breakfast he gave us autographs and we
all walked home that's a dope story like
nothing ever happened
I bet you he would remember that like
nothing ever happened
that's correct remember born in June
when Julius first went to the Sixers he
used to do things on Saturdays he would
do seminars you gotta buy a box of
sneakers the tickets are being the
sneakers so I had the owner Duke up on
49th and Bergen when the owner of that
Congress is a Cuban dude I taught him
I'll give you 40 bucks with the tickets
so he went through all the sneakers have
found two tickets so he did one seminar
at CCNY and the other one affordable
responsive them Congress gave you a
white t-shirt with red
that said converse they they raffled off
the limousines for the feet oh I'll
never forget us waiting online and Julie
is pulling up in a two-door Mercedes
Benz and walking out with a basketball
on his son and he was palming the
basketball and I saw his hands for the
first time and the only [ __ ] died and
then he would do it for how a seminar
where he would break down his his little
stutter step and then he would make you
clap to the other side jump was a foul
line and slam dunk and we would go
[ __ ] crazy we were listening at that
time if julius took his dick out I'd be
the first one sucking it well that was
in the 8th grade
he was first it was a soui was
everything nobody understands per year
what we saw when he was a net when he
was a net which super John Williamson
and big burger Bob what was the fat guy
that the yeah cheeseburger oh my god
don't do this to me not super John um
well super John with tremendous Larry
Kenan was in a while but the
cheeseburger yeah what the [ __ ] was
everybody had the red white and blue
basketball Julius was everything Julius
is everything there was eight categories
he led seven of them or something then
he became a sixer man the fish first it
was funny because people were talking
[ __ ] the other day we were talking about
people that were Beatle fans before John
Lennon died especially if they were
white nothing was good enough in a man I
want to sing let it's gonna be on it
there alright wait to the Beatles get
back to John Williams ja no super 9 you
know wait I went to see Led Zeppelin
yeah whatever way to the Beatles get
back the gentleman gosh I never those
people no more it was the same [ __ ]
thing I've been doc was the [ __ ] best
doctor they just had some bomb in then
they showed people a trucker watching
him at the Rucker League you know and I
was blown away people were hanging on
the [ __ ] roofs and sure all this [ __ ]
he went to school up in Boston somewhere
yeah Massachusetts achoo sits Julius
Erving was everything I love I playoffs
I love Billy Ray microwave Richardson he
was on that book of sugar heart what I'm
sure gray last time I saw him I saw
about the wall he had just written
checks
at a car wash and he got caught for
writing checks this is July of 85 that's
the last time I saw my apparently he's
doing good now he's in Denver Lizzy
because I think he's from Denver who
else is one of my all-time favorite
places uh he played for the Seattle
SuperSonics Gus downtown Freddie Bryant
he was good to gosh the wizard and his
brother yang pass out of the Bronx or
what yeah from I think from Yonkers Gus
was his brother up there with that
little finger you up in Seattle used to
tie his sneakers with the lace behind I
remember I used to see that chin [ __ ]
for that guy I'm talking about was built
like you Lee he felt like he was like I
think mom is like five foot nine on the
chubby side he would sit at the end of
the bench with a brown bag drinking a
beer he [ __ ] yeah what was his name what
did you downtown Freddy Brown that's the
only one I could find his John Williams
and he was nicknamed the hot plate
no no that's on him okay the hot plate
that Center in 1975 then that Center he
had a brother he had also had a brother
that played basketball that's 75 okay
sitting 274 to 75 or so before was 75
all right who was the net set of that um
Billy pulse no he was a fat [ __ ] -
Willie sojourner Willie sojourner yeah
there's all what you said as I see let
me try the other season uh who gives a
[ __ ] don't worry about Mike Rappaport I
gotta tell you something man you've
impressed the [ __ ] out of me appreciate
that Joe the last couple of [ __ ]
years you really have impressed the [ __ ]
out of me you've taken this game by the
pulse I'm not [ __ ] around with these
people Joey you've said nothing's gonna
stop me I'm doing a podcast I yell at
people I'm on I always see on that one
sports show yeah I like the white guy I
disputed
I love with you yard I love those
[ __ ] guys I love them and now I see
you're on stand up you know something
that you went to do 20 or 30 years ago
and gave it a shot
acting bug caught you and you like it I
love it I love the unpredictability of
it and I also love the the you know it's
it's it's a you know it's a [ __ ] it's
like a jigsaw puzzle and and and I love
the the exchange the immediate exchange
from from from the crowd good bad or
indifferent and I just love the
expression like it's like it's your [ __ ]
there's no there's no there's no take -
there's no oh we'll do it again like
it's it's it's an immediate [ __ ]
thing and then you know the craft of it
and and and just you know like just just
the whole the whole the whole feeling of
doing something so that's so immediate I
love it I love it and like we talked
about the adrenaline of it like there's
nothing like that you know and and the
challenge of it like you know just the
the challenging the challenge of it is
is is uh I like it I like you I thought
yeah I'm starting to show uh the third
season of this Netflix show we said we
actually start today well we start
shooting I start shooting tomorrow they
started shooting this show called a
typical so I'm doing that for the next
three months and I'm gonna continue
doing the stand-up office in town
locally yeah yeah yeah you want to
spread your wings and wanna write my
wings but I don't want to overextend
myself like I I still gotta like you
know still still work and [ __ ] and still
you know find my [ __ ] but you know I'm
going out there I'm gonna do uh I'm
gonna do what you're doing the festival
I'm doing some fest I'm doing a couple
of things like Jamaica no Jamaica no
[ __ ] Jamaica there's something that
you're doing it I thought you're doing
your podcast there no no I was [ __ ]
around with that the fire festival too
but I'm doing I'm going to [ __ ] Bellevue
Washington understand that parlor live
in Bellevue Washington you've been there
no I got a warrant to see out I can't go
back are you serious 25 [ __ ] years
your [ __ ] funny can't go back
you never been to the parlor life I'm
going there on extra day April 26 or 27
nine extra by the bull [ __ ] that's
one [ __ ] funny they were I can't go
in but they won't come again that's we
cut [ __ ] funny so I tried to get the
thing paid for and that the case is sold
they can't find it you know you can't do
parlor live no I can't do [ __ ] I can't
even leave the country because of those
I had one more and damn one and I know
but they're both not extradition
can you perform an Idaho yeah now I
can't I think they took care of one but
not in not in Bellevue Washington oh I
can't step foot in the Washington I
could do poor woman give Washington a
finger for stuff that's [ __ ] funny
what are you gonna do this is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you reap what you sow right
no so now I can't go to Seattle I can't
go to Cuba that's [ __ ] funny what I
love it I'm enjoying doing it I'm
enjoying doing it I mean you look good
up there watch you two weeks ago and you
were happy up there you were having a
good time I'm like look at him God
blessing that you know what man a lot of
guys in this town complained
everybody in this town complaints nobody
[ __ ] what does he tell him it was
just on yesterday the movie with the
black kid Jamie Foxx antenna and the
Scientologists oh yeah whatever that
movie yeah yeah yeah it's a good movie
mm darwin you know whatever how the how
to readjust yourself you know if this is
not taking you down the wrong road this
is not going the way you want it you
have to evaluate your life every 90 days
especially here you know you expect you
gonna get 22 auditions also you get 11
and also like you know I don't use this
word artist a lot like I don't I don't
like to throw that word around but I
guess you know I could consider myself
like I was like I'm just an actor who
does it like but the the the artistry of
stand-up and the the exhilaration of
stand-up and the the mathematical scheme
of stand-up and you know this you know
taking a joke taking it
you know how far can you take it pulling
it back like all those things that great
comics do figuring that and learning it
and and and trying to you know get some
sort of you know fundamentals of it I
love it I love it and and and that
artistic expression of you know that
unfiltered thing you know like you know
you know it's it's like meaning with the
coffin you know as much as I love act
and I'm always gonna love it you only
get that sort of that same feeling in
between action and cut and I it's it's
it's exhilarating
it's sexual when you're between action
and cut when I'm acting but when you you
you you're doing it on stage and you
know 20 minutes 40 minutes whatever
you're doing it's like that same thing
but it's like an extended it's like
extended [ __ ] because you get it when
you're acting but you know takes in you
know and you do it but but when you're
doing it 45 minutes like there's an
exhilaration and I and I haven't done it
enough I hope hopefully I'll never it'll
never go away but like during that time
when you're on stage where there's 10
minutes 5 minutes 20 minutes like
there's a an excitement you get right I
mean do you still have that exists so
well I think when it when you don't have
the excitement that's time no that's
when it's time to quit yeah so I love
that I always talked about that how I
like that feeling walking up to the
stage I don't like it you don't like it
but once I touch the stage and touch the
microphone the transformation of those
internal feelings what happens when you
speak into the mic and all those
feelings go away I get a lot of anxiety
still onstage yeah and that's how I know
I love something oh no I'm serious about
ah if I don't care about something will
you right go up there to talk and take
that money and go home right when you're
really concerned about them I want them
to have a good time right I'll [ __ ] up I
want to be funny I want to be able to
hit my marks I want to relax it right
right I want you the science is to be up
there throwing heat but at the same time
you're so relaxed yeah like I just did
Buffalo couple weeks ago at Cassino and
I was so relaxed while
on stage yeah I was hitting all the
notes everything I had looked at before
I went on stage I was hitting them all
proper uh-huh I tried new jokes uh
worked because the energy the excitement
uh uh you learn stand-up is a [ __ ]
long journey like anything else and I
compared it to something like law like I
like watching attorneys ah I'm a fan of
music but I love trial uh watching
attorneys paint a picture for you
they're doing a certain form of standing
yeah yeah yeah well missed and so once
you find out what your style is yeah you
know now you could really attack it yeah
it's finding out yeah it's finding out
and then after you find out then you
have to let your mind and body develop
its own style like your first three or
four years you you're imitating six or
seven comics mm-hmm
not imitating not stealing no I know
what you mean you're imitating uh-huh
and the more you do it the more you come
on it's right when you squeeze that
piece of [ __ ] up right in the head pops
out right it's yeah you've been eatin
bread you haven't been even [ __ ]
opreis
right and it's just you squeeze it you
push your squeeze so that's I still I
still enjoy the fear
I got you I love it too fear you know I
tell people before you rob somebody
before you do something really bad you
go death I used to always go to death I
would hear it that's why I love The
Godfather before he shoots Alonso
because they take the sound of the train
and mix it in with your ears with that
if you're doing something so off kilter
your ears are gonna be ringing mm-hmm
it's so off kilter your adrenaline is
pumping so hard your heart is pumping so
high you start going numb like when
you're gonna rob some money or anything
it could be the other day something
described Tyson walking into the ring
mm-hmm you know that walk then last
thing you should be going through all
these emotions in your system when those
emotions aren't there it's time to go
play tennis I agree
were you gonna be in the next month I'm
gonna be in Bellevue April 26 27 26 26
27 to Bellevue I got to tell all the
people that Joey can't come up here they
know at parler live ain't no and then um
those are the and I got a few other ones
but that's immediate I can't remember I
don't want to look
my phone where can they find you they
can find me anywhere you look on social
media at Michael Rapaport and I got the
I am rapport stereo podcast which I love
doing and Joey's been a guest twice and
I love doing that too and I love doing
the the Church of what's happening right
the [ __ ] now and you squash your beef
with Pauly Shore haha how long was that
before and I was it was quick it was a
short-lived beef I was just a little
beef I thought it was a benign movie you
guys did 20 years ago Pauly's qualities
are good he's a good dude Paul he's a
good he's a [ __ ] pisser listen man
you always got an open door here I
appreciate that came up today I
appreciate that hit the show it's always
a pleasure to see you thankfully the
biggest [ __ ] supporters thank you
Jeff watch your videos and the [ __ ] you
yell at me that's why we had to talk
about snow let one last day ha ha you
think Chicago really prosecute they're
gonna get him on he's getting something
on something I don't know if it's
federal [ __ ] FBI
he's the FBI involved yeah because the
mail stuff I guess like that did the
forging mail like did this ride and it
made too big of a stink of this whole
[ __ ] thing it's it's it's it's too
big of a situated Chris Rock's talking
about it we're talking about it
everybody ever read the [ __ ] podcast
is talking about reduce I didn't I don't
feel bad listen like I just told you you
know what the Sun the even the host dog
gets a warm spot on the sidewalk once in
a while something happened he gotta go
to check look at what's going on when I
whine stick you haven't heard nothing
he's playing him like a fiddle he's
playing them like an old-school Jew he's
giving him money to keep the trial keep
him keep pushing it back he's deciding
on his legal counsel it's a whole school
trick yeah
well I don't know how I feel about it
that's a [ __ ] give him 20 he's gotta get
yeah I just want you're doing six months
you're doing something you're doing he's
doing he's gonna do apologize what the
[ __ ] you did it just irresponsibly
didn't kill anybody didn't hurt me but
it's just irresponsible
again he's a guy that whoa somebody's
dreams listen I'm gonna being a stand-up
and gonna vanish uh big acting
and there were girls that when my book
something would say you got me a meeting
with your agent I'll do anything for you
so yeah can you imagine having a movie
yeah it's just it's a it's just a
Hollywood disgusting
Oh Harvey was it's a Hollywood disgust
door yeah and rape is very hard to prove
rape is very hard to prove especially if
it's years ago if he's very smart
it'll get investigators to break balls
because the last thing your girlfriend
wants is for me to call her old
boyfriend because that's what's gonna
happen see now when they get this team
they're gonna start a rat man or acid
it's an investigator hi we want to talk
to you about Michael Rapaport I'm good
friends of Michael I've known for six
years we work together on Copland did he
ever what happens when that investigator
leaves you're gonna call me no listen I
just got over here
what what are you talking about
investigator the last thing you know I
started getting more call and awesome
that's what drives these women crazy to
relive that mm-hmm they have to go back
into a trial and relive that and again
and again and that's why he has to hire
two women right to go Adam to call them
guts to call them Liars to say you know
we checked your parrot what about the
for the guy you [ __ ] the night before
mmm do you have sex the night before
with some little Chinese guy in the
village you could ecstasy with him well
what what does that have to do it all
right
oh you did actually maybe you didn't
know your frame alone at the time the
attorneys job is to put a doubt over
what would happen here I doubt I'll just
a doubt just to make you think of doubt
I see how are we playing the [ __ ]
system oh yeah okay I see how are we
playing this is Bobby wasn't smart
enough to play the system he was just an
ignorant dumb [ __ ] he was too stupid bad
[ __ ] guys in jail he's in jail in
that crazies of jail he need to play the
system and I'm excited this system he
could all he had to do was take a long
supper cash out and put on the table
safe play these [ __ ] get all these
[ __ ] lie-detector tests
keep [ __ ] going at him he just wanted
to be mr. [ __ ] mr. Dores in American
thought he was gonna be cool and smile
and crack a joke it wasn't about that
you got three women there
and like I said in the beginning how
many [ __ ] witnesses are really all
this [ __ ] I piece everything together
for me they live in this [ __ ] city
anymore on this disgust I have to put
all these things together from Harvey to
Jessie this is what happens when you
hear when you want something that bad
that you put a noose around your neck
and make up a story like that and you
want some bad that you already got to me
we [ __ ] around a lie about this we
exaggerate this story we exaggerate that
story but for me to put a noose around
me go to the hospital tell them I got
beat up by two guys I want you to think
about that you're not what drives that
it's a thing called Hollywood I mean
they passed Marilyn Monroe around to my
[ __ ] to the death didn't everybody all
Marilyn well I [ __ ] her to death [ __ ]
to the death then would never wonder
when she got the safe in the hip this
yellow creature called they killed a
[ __ ] but do you think when when we
leave in the parking lot now we're not
recording now right maybe you and Lee
could smack me around cuz I got
something I'm trying to do liked it like
this but make it like make aware it's
like bruises control we're not recording
anymore right can't do it because I'm
friends with year and a half to your
motion no no it's fine it's fine I have
a friend that fly out into a plate glass
window but we're not recording now right
because I yeah we're always record okay
oh [ __ ] we are recording I didn't want
to get that on tape don't worry about
mother I love you cousin Thank You Joey
we gonna take them guys don't forget
Pittsburgh is sold out your dad got left
in the month of April is 4:20 we added a
second show up to the Pabst Theater my
maid dates have been rescheduled I will
hit you with the new dates by the end of
the week I'm very sorry
San Antonio Dallas Detroit and Omaha
have to be rescheduled for September or
November because I got a movie and
that's it and that's that I want to
thank Michael Rapaport I want to thank
the [ __ ] I don't want to thank
you [ __ ] for listening all
right but I want also want to thank our
sponsors we got the best monsters in the
world starts out with manscape let me
tell you somethin time my wife cream is
my balls
around my dick I'm [ __ ] sweating
bullets not anymore you know why
cuz manscape don't cut off your dick
[ __ ] all the suffering in today with
manscape you get it done without the
pain without the anxiety without the
nerves rattling they got precision tools
for the family jewels okay their
invention is the lawnmower
a handheld razor with skin-safe
technology so it won't snick or snag
your ball sack or cut the star minchia
stick or nuttin you gotta go easy on
what the Lord gave you guys this bad boy
will leave you a nice smooth clean and
pain-free Plus it's rechargeable and
easy the holes you can get it to all
those little nooks and crannies you
could trim your [ __ ] [ __ ] hairs
whatever you need manscape will do a
Fiat manscape will get that beanbag
looking as smooth as a [ __ ] egg and
I'm gonna let you in on a little secret
all right if you trim the hedges the
tree looks taller so what are you
waiting for trim up that [ __ ] egg grow
right now and get your party started
they also have [ __ ] ball wipe they
also have a revival spritz that tones
refreshing your junk to keep it cool
they got the crop preserver especially
formulated the order and so your balls
won't stick like [ __ ] billy goats
they got the perfect package that comes
with a lawn mower and a safety razor
Plus this is the time to consider
manscape right now it's that time of the
year that's it it's [ __ ] springtime
you're out there you don't want your
ball you meet new people you're going on
dates you want the balls to smell like
[ __ ] Newark [ __ ] no that's why the
church family gets 20% off your first
order when you use promo code church at
manscape calm and if you order the
perfect package they throw in a
beautiful little [ __ ] travel bag I
got one myself it fits everything the
[ __ ] crop raiser
the ball wipe the [ __ ] revive
everything fits in there
so do me a favor go to manscape com use
promo code Church and they'll give you
20% off your first order and don't
forget that perfect package cuz they
throw on the free travel bag number one
manscape calm and always remember you
got to keep the [ __ ] nuts clean okay
listen
picking a CBD company is like [ __ ]
getting a [ __ ] [ __ ] without the
hill I don't [ __ ] know lucky for you
we got CBD line they make CBD products
from start to fit
CBD line as you covered it comes in a
vape with cartridges it comes in a
shadow it comes in a tension
it comes in gummies you cannot [ __ ]
lose I used attention to three times a
[ __ ] day I put it onto my tongue
dirty sentence you swallow man you're a
brand-new man their products are clean
Bobby and there aren't like the faced at
the fight with fake advertising at these
[ __ ] little reliable stores you're
going to they got [ __ ] they got nothing
listen going to trusted winner CBD lying
calm and for the church family I'm gonna
give you 20% off when you order check
out with [ __ ] Church CH you are CH
and I'm gonna give you the best CBD
everybody asks me what's the best CBD
around CBD line you know why cuz they
back up their [ __ ] so go to CBD line
right now and put in Church and check
out and get 20% off and as usual my
family over it on it the best whether
it's out for brain shroom tech sport
shroom tech immune the protein powder
listen this is the way to get your body
in tip-top shape the Alpha brain if you
do a lot of writing thinking you're
overwhelmed alpha brain is the way to go
what I'm gonna do for you today is go to
on it take a look around I can't help
you with the kettlebells or anything
else but I can help you with the
supplements and these supplement you see
me if I was just starting out when I'm
on it I'd start with alpha brain and
Shoom take a moon immune just start with
those two give them a [ __ ] whiz and
let me know what you think if you're not
happy with the alpha brain there's a
hundred percent money-back guarantee and
guess what I didn't want the product
back that's how much they believe in
their product so going on at that time
right now press in church boom I get 10
percent off your order delivered to your
door again I want to thank manscape calm
I want to thank on it and I want to
thank CB beeline calm but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for listening believing
and supporting us all right I'll see you
guys Thursday morning have a great
[ __ ] day and have a great week stay
black kick this [ __ ] mealy